- Hi, I'm Jen.
- And I'm Ricky.
- And welcome to the best of Buzzfeed!
(screaming)
- Dial it back!
- Reel it in!
- Wrap it up!
(cheering)
- How do you do this?
This is so hard!
- We are going to still do the things
that we do every day.
- Masturbate.
- No, we are not fucking doing that.
(laughs)
- [Jen] That was pretty funny.
- We just watched some
of the funniest clips
from the past two weeks of Buzzfeed,
and I think we're gonna watch some more.
We're gonna bring in some familiar faces
that you might recognize,
and uh, come along!
- It's gonna be one hell of a time.
So Ricky and I are producers here,
which means that we edit and craft
a lot of the videos you see, and
we sort of want to know
what you guys think.
- Yeah, a lot of people actually think
that we don't read the comments.
But we do.
- Oh, we do.
- And then I cry myself to sleep.
- You wanna read the first comment?
- Yes.
♫ Comment hunting, comment hunting
♫ First ♫
- So our first comment.
- [Jen] This is a comment from the video
Stuff Your Cat Does That Would
Be Rude For Your Roommate To Do.
It's from user name oVizions.
- [Ricky] "I was gonna
make a chemistry joke,
but all the good ones argon."
- It's a pun, someone
made a chemistry pun.
- Does anyone know what argon is--
- Argon is an element.
- Well, what kind of element?
- [Jen] It's a gas.
- [Ricky] Ooh, it's a gas!
- All right--
- Oh, I get it.
- The joke is "I was gonna
make a chemistry joke
but all the good ones are a gas."
- Regardless, you know what?
- It's a pun, you know, it's a pun!
The person that made this
comment ruined my life!
- Yeah.
This is actually from
a video I made, called
People Who Are Afraid
Of Bees Play With Bees.
And this comes from the
user John Glasscock.
(laughs)
- What does John Glasscock have to say?
- I don't know, you tell me, Jen.
- [Jen] "Next video: People
who are afraid of drowning
drink water."
- 58 upvotes.
- Good word, old Glasscock.
- Okay, all jokes aside,
great, funny comment.
He's kinda making fun of us, fair enough.
- Actually, you know what?
If people who were afraid
of drowning drink water--
- I wanna see that.
- [Jen] Facing their fears.
- [Ricky] Yeah.
- And quenching their thirst.
- Wow.
All right, wanna check
out the next comment?
- [Jen] Yes.
Please, hit me with the next comment.
- [Ricky] This is from a video called
The High Guys Decorate Cakes,
and this comes from Toast.
Whoever Toast is is so committed to toast.
His avatar is toast.
- [Jen] And his name is Toast.
"I want Chris to smear
frosting on my toasted body."
- I love it, I love it.
- He is so committed to toast!
- This is Toast.
God, and I just see Toast
scrolling the Internet,
like "God, there's gotta be
a good toast comment for me today,"
and then he stumbles upon cakes,
he's like "this is me!"
And then he, ba-doom-ba-doom-doom!
- He's like "put that
frosting on my toast, Chris."
- Yeah.
- All right, well, I think
that's enough comments for now.
We got some other cool stuff to do.
- Speaking of cool shit, did you know
that this actually isn't
me and Jen's apartment?
This is a Buzzfeed set!
Check it out.
- What!
- Oh my god, movie magic!
- We don't actually even live together.
- Yeah.
What?
- [Ricky] What?
- [Jen] What?
- Next on the agenda, we're gonna go meet
a Buzzfeed producer and pick their brains.
(laughs)
Sorry.
Okay.
- Let's go.
Oh, God.
Let's go boys.
♫ Jen and Ricky ♫
I have a pretty short--
- Whoa!
- Hi!
- Oh hey, this is Caroline.
She makes all the cool Nifty videos
that you like on Facebook.
- [Jen] Yeah.
- [Ricky] Bye, Caroline.
- Bye, Caroline.
- Cool, so uh, this is--
They're shooting Lingerie
Through The Ages right now.
What age is this?
- I am the 18th century, a.k.a.
when no one got laid, apparently.
- Wow.
- Hey, guys!
- Hey!
- What's up!
- Hey, uh, do you wanna come back
to our house and watch some clips?
- Okay.
- All right.
- Hey, guys.
- So, welcome to our lovely abode.
- Thank you!
- [Ricky] Safiya, in your opinion,
what's the craziest Buzzfeed
video that you've ever made?
- One time I made a video about auras.
With like, a semi-crazy person.
I did also make a lady
eat beauty products.
- Those are fun.
- No, I mean--
- They're fine.
- Yeah.
- This one, however.
- Is the craziest!
- The craziest video.
- We have a box of
unopened pads from 1975.
It's a little, like, erotic?
(laughs)
In a weird way.
Like, it has a hand on my
vagina, you know what I mean?
- We can confirm, this is the
sexiest we've ever looked.
- It's crazy to think
how period technology
has improved, literally,
in the past few years
versus, like, all of female history.
- I should point out, I do love the phrase
"period technology."
(laughs)
- Why did you make this video?
- There's no handbook for
"the best thing for your body"
you know what I mean?
So you really have to rely
on other women's experiences.
- So this is cool, because you're kind of
taking part in writing the handbook
for a newer generation of people.
- Yes.
Though if I were to recommend a book,
The Care and Keeping of You--
- I had that!
- Yes!
- [Safiya] Such a relevant book.
It's The Care and Keeping Of You.
- I didn't have that one.
- The very, like, diverse cover.
How well did this video do?
- This video got, I think,
2.8 million views in one week.
- That's amazing.
- Kind of was a perfect storm of, like,
ladylike, Ingrid Nilson, and periods, man,
'cause we wanna talk about periods.
- So, before we go on to
the next section, Saf,
we just want to show you a fun--
A cute little clip of you
when you were a baby intern.
- Oh, no.
♫ When they were interns ♫
- And we just thought
it'd be fun to revisit.
It's when you were in the
Charlie Charlie video.
- I know what this is.
I am so superstitious, I
don't know why I'm doing this.
- Charlie Charlie, can we play?
(screams)
- No!
Charlie Charlie, will you appear?
(spooky music)
- What?
- I'm Charlie.
- Hi.
(dramatic chord)
No, I'm not possessed!
- Oh my God, oh my God, oh my God!
- Great job.
(laughs)
- I'm gonna own up, that is actually
exactly what I thought.
I did think he was possessed
for about a half a second.
I really did.
- [Ricky] Wow.
- I consider myself an intelligent person,
but that was not my, you
know, brightest moment.
- Well, thank you for sharing
your intimate past with us!
So on Buzzfeed, we also
love to make food videos,
a.k.a. Tasty.
So we're gonna watch the top Tasty videos
of the past couple weeks,
with the High Guys!
♫ Tasty bites ♫
All right, let's bring out
Brandon from the High Guys!
- Whoo!
- Brandon!
Hey, man.
- Hey.
- [Ricky] What's up, Brandon?
- [Jen] Welcome, welcome.
- [Ricky] Come take a seat.
- Please, join us, join us.
(sighs)
- Oh, this is nice.
- All right, let's
watch some Tasty videos!
Upside down banana cake.
- [Brandon] Upside down.
- [Safiya] Ooh, ripe bananas!
- [Brandon] Ooh.
- [Jen] That pretty yellow color.
- That looks like--
Ooh.
- [Jen] Does it feel like "ooh"?
- [Brandon] I wanna just rub that--
That stuff looks like
it can go on my belly,
on top and inside.
Okay.
- [Safiya] Wow, that looks great.
- [Brandon] Cinnamon, what the heck?
Oh, that's caramel!
See, I like caramel, 'cause
I'm the same color as caramel.
- [Ricky] Oh my god, a caramel man!
- Exactly.
Oh, God, Jesus Christ.
- [Jen] It's beautiful.
- [Brandon] Oh my god!
- [Jen] Yeah, oh--
(laughs)
Whoa!
- [Brandon] That's crazy.
- [Safiya] That's beautiful.
- [Brandon] This is the cake of gods.
Banana gods.
- [Jen] Oh my gosh.
- [Safiya] Whoa, that looks beautiful!
- [Jen] It does!
- Oh my god.
Wait, wait, pause this for a second!
Can we just admire this beauty?
- Where did the ice cream come from?
- Ice cream, oh, lots of ice cream.
- [Jen] This could be good--
- [All] Oh!
- [Ricky] Melting!
- That was too sexual.
- Tasty videos are--
There's, like, a weird
sexual element sometimes.
- Well, it's called
food porn for a reason.
- Oh, that's right!
- Dude, Tasty, the finest in food porn.
- See, I'm fat, food porn is
like regular porn to me, so...
- [Safiya] Pizza bombs!
- [Brandon] Pizza bombs.
Oh my god.
- [Safiya] Oh, it's so cute.
- Look at it, it looks like
a baby being delivered.
- [Jen] Looks like a little ball.
- [Brandon] Wow.
- [Jen] Garlic, salt and
pepper, Italian seasoning.
- [Brandon] Ooh! You do
that, like, too quick--
- [Jen] You can baste that.
Pizza bombs!
- [All] Mmm.
- [Brandon] Wait a minute,
look at that sauce.
I wanna dip it in the sauce.
- [Safiya] Yes!
- [Ricky] Yeah!
- [Brandon] The, what is that?
Is that cocktail--
What is that?
- [Jen] Marinara.
- [Brandon] Marinara!
- [Jen] Whoa.
- Yeah, I could definitely
eat 30 of those.
"We're gonna show you the food!
But you can't eat it.
Ha ha ha."
(laughs)
- Okay, Brandon, so we're not cruel enough
that we're gonna show you
a bunch of food videos
without feeding you some awesome food.
(gasps)
- No way!
Are you serious?
Wait a minute, what?
- That is food, that's real food.
Hey, man.
- You're a beautiful man.
- Hey, you, you're dope.
- Can we eat?
Let's eat.
Everybody grab a pizza bomb.
Oh my god.
- I thought you just--
Did you put the whole thing in your mouth?
- Yeah, whole one.
- You ate one already?
- Tastes like cheese and bread.
(laughs)
It takes like what Jesus would eat.
- These are so good,
it's like my childhood
wrapped up into one
little bun of awesomeness.
- Are these carbs?
Any carbs in there?
(laughs)
I can't eat carbs.
- The ultimate test is the
glamour shot at the end, right?
- [Jen] Ooh yeah.
- That's what I'm talking about.
Slow-mo that, slow-mo that shit.
- [Voiceover] Slow motion.
- See, you see how Ricky ate that?
That's how I eat hot
wings at a strip club.
(laughs)
Right down the middle!
- So that's it for our show.
- We hope you enjoyed it!
- Yeah, Brandon, Safiya,
thanks for coming by.
- Thanks for having us!
- Thank you, thank you, thank you.
- So we'll see you around next time!
- Yeah.
Thanks, everybody!
- Bye!
- For watching our show!
Shout out to John Glasscock!
- Who's that?
- You'll find out.
- Oh, you'll see.
- [Brandon] Ooh.